what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome
Auntie Jenny hi how's it going to clap
yeah
start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification Bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos like the video on your
way and also guys consider dropping a
super thanks you know to support the
channel so today auntie
there is a conservative media guy I've
never heard of him that's unusual but
apparently he's important because
everyone's talking about it
[Laughter]
um he he apparently said some statements
that were controversial on a talk show
that's never happened before never
happened and people are canceling him
and like the beta he seems to be he
apologized anyways pull up the pull up
the clip blessing we'll see we'll see if
you think that it's all the talk about
age makes me uncomfortable I think that
I think it's the wrong road to go down
she says people you know
um so to give you context
um Nikki Haley is running for president
and she was saying that there should be
cognitive ability tests for older people
running for for president I remember
saying that yeah yeah and so that's
that's the context of this conversation
okay we'll talk about age makes me
uncomfortable I think that I think it's
the wrong road to go down she says
people you know politicians are
something and not in their Prime Nikki
Haley isn't in a prime sorry when a
woman is considered being a prime in her
20s and 30s and maybe 40s that's not
according to me Prime for what it
depends I mean it's just like Prime oh
stop it she knows exactly what he's
saying she knows exactly what he's
saying what he didn't sound nervous
whilst he made such a good statement he
made the factual statement then once she
started he was just like um well you
know he should have stood on it because
he's right yeah he is he's right if you
look if you Google when is a woman in
her prime it'll say 20s 30s and 40s I
don't know 40. so I got it I'm not
saying I agree with that so I think she
has to be careful about saying that you
know politicians aren't in their privacy
you need to qualify are you talking
about Prime for like child preparing or
are you talking about
President the facts are Google and
everybody at home when is a woman in her
prime it says 20s 30s and 40s and I'm
just saying Nikki Haley should be it
does not say 40s he's just saying that
to be nice to the woman in the white top
does not say
foreignties if that's the case say 50s
please
I want to be in my pride
well it's just like he's right so I
don't know why the hell these girls are
this is what this is why modern women
are delusional you know why because
they're over 30s for and they're over
20s they're over 30s and that lady there
she said thank you I'm in my 40s that
could mean anything she could be like
nearly 50. all about saying that
politicians are not in their Prime and
they need to be in their Prime when they
serve because she wouldn't be in a prime
according to
Google Google or whatever it is he
should have said according to men yeah
but then everything goes back to Google
what she should have said is that they
need to be tested when they reach the
legal age to draw their pension that
would have been better and then
everybody would be at the same 65
because men reached their Prime
different to women so when she said
Prime she uh she shot herself in the
foot because men are going to reach
their Prime older than women well I
think the whole idea is like what
because who decides what's cognitively
there you know what I mean so like then
like you're putting a third person in
control of deciding who gets like I
could just see someone taking advantage
of that if they don't want a certain
party to win and how they would make the
test if I was losing I'd slip you some
money you know get a corrupt doctor to
say yeah she's fine but I feel that's
why I feel like it should be for the
people to decide like there shouldn't be
a test yeah to prove that because my
it's not even that the test doesn't make
sense on some level it's that who
decides what tests proves that someone
is cognitively there I think the results
prove it I mean by your present
president and all that you can tell you
know dementias
you know let him run for a few years
when he messes up say right he's not
with it and then it's not true the
public vote him out yeah yeah exactly I
mean Kevin Samuels would say leftover
[Laughter]
yeah that is how we met was because I I
mean I was so nervous I was like damn I
gotta say this to this nice lady's face
yeah and then because you shut up so
early too oh I hate being late I hate
being late yeah and then I was like so I
asked Eric are women left over after 35
and you were like yeah you're like hell
yeah
then I'll say to them they said no
Auntie's girl I said no I'm not what
makes me different from them I remember
because he had a heart attack when I
said I'm a leftover woman
myself all the haters out there I've
already said it I said it in the
beginning I said it on the very first
show I went on the very first show she
went on okay I'm a leftover woman in a
relationship but right okay we have the
we have the the reference I made to a
woman's Prime this morning was it
hurtful was hurtful
as corley's and loved ones pointed out
and I regret it wimp a woman's age
doesn't Define her personally or
professionally I have countless women in
my life who prove her every day
no because
just just be real let's just be real the
18 year olds look hotter than the 28
year olds the 28 year olds look hotter
than the 38 year olds by and large let's
be real by obesity alone obesity alone I
want to pick out what he said he said he
made a reference he didn't make a
reference because he said go to Google
he was referencing where it was he said
it was hurt but only relevant it was
only hurtful to those who have passed
their Prime and it wasn't irrelevant
because it is relevant because that's
what he's talking about and his
colleagues and if they loved him they
wouldn't have pointed it out and he
regrets it what a wimp a woman's age
doesn't differ doesn't Define her well
if that's the case I'm 25 again I'm 25.
I don't want to be old
I'm Gonna Be Young don don why'd you
apologize my man you should not have
apologized I wish he stood on that so
the only thing I wish he said when he
said a woman's Pastor Prime and she's
like to who men yeah I wish she didn't
say that obviously said the Chinese oh
go to China and see they're called
leftovers and then that would have hurt
even more they call them leftover women
in China yeah what makes you special
because she's old and she's entitled and
she's on TV and she thinks she looks
good she thinks she's better than she is
yeah I mean she she does look good you
didn't think so for somebody past their
Prime yes
okay guys um let me know what you guys
think in the comments um don't forget to
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell like the video on your
way out and make sure you subscribe to
Auntie Jenny's Channel yeah it'd be nice
because I know I'm post my Prime so
don't say nothing because I already know
I'm past my Prime you know he didn't
even mention the 50 so you know I'm long
gone me too I hit 26. yeah so yeah yeah
you push it is it well this the wall is
approaching the wall the wall okay the
wall is undefeated I'm learning
okay like the video on your way out guys
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell I'll talk to you next
time